hi everyone welcome to
today's homeroom uh very excited about
the conversation we are about to have i
will start with my standard reminder uh
reminding everyone that khan academy is
a not-for-profit organization we can
only exist through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to donate
please think about that
i also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations that have
played a a really big role helping us to
close the gap that we've had we actually
had a gap even before covid and then
with kovid you can imagine our server
costs and we've been trying to
accelerate a bunch of programs to help
folks out with the distance learning uh
so special thanks to bank of america
google.org at t fastly novartis and
actually the amgen foundation as well
and the many other foundations
individual donors and corporate partners
over the years because it's really that
support that's allowed khan academy to
be
so hopefully essential or useful during
this very uncertain times we're facing
an education
with that i'm really excited to
introduce our guest martha jones who's a
professor historian at johns hopkins
university uh thanks so much for joining
us martha
i'm really happy to be here thanks for
having me
so
uh a lot to talk about but maybe the
most uh uh time uh the thing most
relative to what day it is it's the
hundredth anniversary of women's right
to vote the 19th amendment getting
ratified
you know we learned a certain narrative
there about you know susan b anthony and
seneca falls and the suffragettes and
then
1920 women have the right to vote which
every time i say that it feels a lot
later than like my brain does a check it
was it really that late
is
but you're an expert in this space you
know if you could tell us a little bit
about a little more color on that
narrative you know what what are we
getting right in the traditional history
books and then maybe what more texture
is going to help us fill in the gaps
sure
so you're right to point to the story i
think a lot of us have encountered
the women's
road to the vote begins in 1848 in a
village in upstate new york seneca falls
and culminates
um more than 70 years later in
uh
the ratification of the 19th amendment
in
1920. um and i think this is a year for
us to
rethink some of the myths and some of
the misunderstandings about that story
i tell a story that begins in the
earliest decades of the 19th century as
american women including
african-american women are
first and foremost developing a
political philosophy right a critique of
the
position that they occupy or the
positions they don't occupy in american
politics and that requires um
criticizing both racism and sexism and
the ways in which they keep american
women particularly black american women
at the margins of politics
now i wish i could tell you that in 1920
american women got the vote
but the 19th amendment doesn't guarantee
the vote to any american women and black
american women will continue to be
disenfranchised
even after 1920 by state laws
that
are designed to keep them and their
husbands and their fathers if you will
from the polls so when i tell this story
it begins in that early sort of
philosophical
reflections by african-american women
and it takes us all the way forward to
1965
when we have federal legislation finally
that gives teeth to the 19th amendment
and now
guarantees to all black americans
including black
women the right to vote it turns out to
be a much
longer story and in some ways a more
troubled story than the one we might
have encountered
in our schools in our textbooks or maybe
even in popular culture
and i want to and this is super valuable
i want to encourage folks to ask
questions on facebook and youtube we
have team members who will be surfing
the surfacing those questions to myself
and martha you know one question that
i've always had even before i really
understood the nuance that you just
alluded to is
why do you think it took so long what
was the rest of the world doing was the
u.s kind of late to the game was it
early to the game and how do you see
these parallel movements uh that as you
just pointed out to some degree
converged over time where you had the
the suffragette movement the women's
right to vote movement and then of
course you had uh coming out of the
civil war the right for at least
african-american males in theory uh to
to be able to be citizens and vote
in history how are those weighed against
each other and did they help each other
were they just two separate movements
so where does the u.s sit in this story
um relatively early
the
19th amendment follows just on the heels
of
transformation for example for british
women
but will take many more decades for
example for women in france to
win the right to vote and so
it's a long story about how
women in the world come to power we
could come forward to the founding of
the united nations where you have then
women from across the globe coming to
talk about colonialism
the legacy of slavery
and how
women of color across the globe share a
ongoing concern about oppression
so this is a this is a big story not a
small one um but to take us to the story
in the u.s and the relationship between
um would have been two important radical
social movements on the one hand
anti-slavery and on the other hand
women's rights both having their origins
in the decades before the civil war
it turned out to be an uneasy
relationship
that by the time we get to the 1860s and
remember that in the 1860s the
constitution is being rewritten a
revolution is happening in the united
states
slavery is abolished birthright
citizenship is established and as you
alluded to the 15th amendment is going
to prohibit
states from using race as a criteria in
meeting out voting rights
um
within this old and important political
coalition there is really a
extraordinary range of views
some who advocate
educated suffrage is the way forward
which is oftentimes a way of alluding to
um white suffrage and particularly the
suffrage for white women um others will
make the case that for african-american
men the vote is a matter of life and
death that they are facing not only
political challenges but
literal challenges
when it comes to their
physical well-being
black men need the vote in order to
protect themselves um in that story i
always like to introduce a third
position if you will and that is one
taken by an african-american woman in
these meetings francis ellen watkins
harper who comes to the meeting
to challenge both of these
positions why because black women of
course can't
pull apart
um their race from their sex they live
at the crossroads of these two vexed
positions in american politics and
watkins harper
urges this coalition to stay together um
and to
as she puts it
work for the interests of all humanity
and this will become
the core of how black women approach the
question of women's rights going forward
this keen eye yes on their own political
empowerment but for
a broader interest right for how black
women can then work use political power
to serve the needs of their families
their communities but as watkins harper
puts it um one great bundle of humanity
and so
we can see the stage being set for
many approaches to thinking about voting
rights in the united states going
forward and you're right to point out
that african american men while briefly
they will enjoy the vote after the civil
war will find themselves disenfranchised
um and black women will
in a in a twisted sense and join them um
after 1920 now seemingly
authorized to vote by the constitution
and still kept away from the polls by
laws and by violence and intimidation
especially in southern states that is
aimed at keeping
black americans uh out of the body
politic
and i want to focus a little bit on the
time in which it happened you know 1920
you know just to give everyone
historical context obviously we had just
finished the great war not you know
later we learned it's world war one uh
we we actually were
uh i think still going through her in
the later stages of a global pandemic uh
the the spanish flu
was that relevant to a women finally
getting the right to vote what was the
argument before why did it take so many
decades from seneca falls until 1920
which we normally associate with a
fairly modern time
yes so um
it's important sometimes i think when we
say women's suffrage um it somehow
exceptionalizes this political movement
from um everything that's happening
around it so you're so right to point to
um
the election of woodrow wilson the entry
of the u.s into what becomes the first
world war um the flu pandemic
all of these things
challenge
the women who are leading the fight for
what becomes the 19th amendment there
are those who think for example that
american women should if you will stand
down from the fight for voting rights
once the u.s enters the war effort
somehow it's unseemly right to challenge
the state or to burden it when it's a
time for
a kind of cohesion a national cohesion
around the war effort
and at the same time those there are
those suffragists in the u.s who see the
war as an opportunity
to
if you will turn up the fire
on the feet of the wilson administration
um as we know alice paul will lead um
picketers women who will
stand outside the white house
even into the war um with placards with
signs
that challenge the administration that
begin to liken
the wilson administration to
authoritarian leaders in europe because
they will not sign off on a women's
suffrage amendment so
this um struggle is very much caught up
here
the pandemic the flu pandemic provides
american women with another opportunity
if you will particularly african
american women um understand it is an
opportunity to
show themselves to be um
loyal effective committed citizens i
write about mary church terrell a
suffrage leader in daytona florida who
transforms her girls school in a small
hospital into a major facility for
treating those who have been stricken by
the flu
this is a way that terrell
embeds herself and her politics into
this local community
even as the struggle for the vote is
still going on
so women's politics is not
an exception from what's happening
women's politics is
interlaced with many of the histories
that we already know and if i could say
i think for educators this is important
and useful um because there are some
subjects that are
in our curricula
and others that may not be and sometimes
when we can make those connections it
helps us to widen the scope of lessons
but it also helps students to
situate new stories um amidst the kinds
of stories they may already know
yeah absolutely because you know the
traditional narrative in a lot of these
things is you know decades of protest
and organizing and at some point
essentially the men said yeah i guess i
guess we'll let them vote uh but to your
point
maybe there's a little bit of that but
uh there's a lot of a historical context
as we saw in both world wars uh as men
went to go to fight uh society had to
lean much more heavily on on women to
even keep society going and i suspect
that that that also
played up played a major role there's a
great question here from youtube from
joshua cataville saying the question is
how have the ideas behind women and
women's empowerment evolved over time so
we're talking you know we're
commemorating the 100 year anniversary
of the 19th amendment women women
getting the right to vote in the united
states but that's clearly not been the
end of
of whatever you want to call it women
trying to ensure that they have more
equal rights
in our society so how has that evolved
over the last hundred years and where do
you think we are
well i think one measure is um that
which is
if you will right under our nose um
sitting here in august of 2020 and that
is yet again
a major party
with a woman
on the ticket
in this case senator kamala harris on
the democratic party's ticket um
this while not unthinkable in 1920 is
almost
unimaginable on the other hand and
particularly
because the 19th amendment rests so
heavily on the assumption that black
women will remain without the vote will
remain outside of politics even after
1920.
when we have
senator harris on the ticket
it's hard to resist the conclusion that
something has changed
that african-american women for example
have
worked deliberately consistently
creatively
to
transform their place in american
politics nobody gives women much in this
story
but we certainly see many examples how
about of how women um earn things when
things take things um across the course
of this history and so i think on the on
that measure um i would say that we um
can recognize the transformation um that
we've uh lived through at least
figuratively not all of us have lived
for the hundred years but uh
figuratively the transformation
and if we if we
looked then into the
fabric of american politics we would
recognize um
something like 250 american women
running for congress
this year
nearly half of them women of color
that is a
radical sea change from 100 years ago
that rests
to an important degree upon the 19th
amendment
rests to an important degree upon the
voting rights act in 1965
and of course
rests on women's insistence that they
are not only um
forceful candidates for these offices
but positioning themselves for when
i like to say when the rest of the
country catches up
women are ready and we saw that as joe
biden vetted
more than a dozen women um for the vice
presidency and we all
had to study and
figure out not only who they were but
how they were similar how they were
different it was a rich and diverse
slate of women who were vying for that
office and that is one sort of testament
to what has changed since 1920.
and do you think you know we've been
talking so far as women's right to vote
you know that's something that should
happen you have half the population that
was disenfranchised
how do you think women getting the right
to vote and then actually acting on that
right and being able to act on that
right especially over the last
especially since 1965 how do you think
that's changed the nature of our
democracy has it changed the type of
policies we we enact or don't enact how
we act in foreign policy
our laws generally
that's a great question i think that um
that force is still um
if you will gaining momentum um but i'm
interested in the question of what we
think women's issues are you know one of
the things that's said in 1920 for
example is that racism is not a women's
issue that somehow race is an
african-american issue
but i think today our sense of sort of
what the boundaries of women's issues
are um are are really shifting right so
that when we speak about um relief
related to the coronavirus um whether
it's for business owners or it's for
individual heads of households
whether it's for schools
these are all i think today
understood to be women's issues in a way
that doesn't exceptionalize american
women but recognizes how american women
are absolutely at the center of nearly
any major question
that we might ask but i do think there
is another
i guess a layer another layer to your
question um
because
there is
particularly from anti-suffragist in
1920 the assertion um that american
women will make no difference at the
polls because they will
merely if you will vote like their
husbands and their fathers right so it
won't change the balance of power
between parties won't change the outcome
on election day it won't change
or influence law making women are like
men
but it turns out that
one of the troubles with the 19th
amendment is that while white american
women
are expected to in a sense split between
the two parties like their husbands and
fathers are split
black american women are expected to
vote as a block
and we see with 1920 the small numbers
of black women who do vote do indeed
vote as a bloc they support the
republican party in those years and it's
candidates and while that doesn't tip
the balance of power nationally it can
tip the outcome of elections locally and
at the state level
black women from the city of chicago
will be critical to the election of
oscar de priest to the u.s congress in
1928
de priest is the first african-american
man to be elected to congress since
reconstruction so two almost three
generations and um and this is because
black women in chicago have learned how
to use their uh their power at the polls
to change the outcome of elections um
and to vote as a block in a way that
does tip the balance
in 1928 when oscar de priest runs and
much more recently in 2017
when senator doug jones runs in the
state of alabama 98 of black women vote
for him and they are the slim margin
that flips that seat from red to blue in
the state of alabama so um
this um
fear
that gets expressed about how women's
votes might be
a game changer turns out to be founded
and i'm curious you know given where we
are you mentioned kamala harris before
that we've had geraldine ferraro and we
had sarah palin
you know obviously there's policy
difference between the democrats and the
republicans but if
uh if kamala harris does become the next
vice president
what do you think that will mean for
this hundred year long movement do you
think it will you know obviously it's
symbolically very very powerful do you
think it will somehow change governance
will get women more active in politics
and then what do you think is the next
leg of the journey on actually both of
these
these these strands we're talking about
both on the the issue of women's rights
and on the issue of civil rights
generally
when i think about your question
my mind goes to my
daughters and really to my
granddaughters
and
i don't think we have to imagine long to
appreciate
the way in which
not only senator harris but senator
harrison is as an example
of how
the
ambitions the imaginations
and the political lives of young women
are being transformed in this very
moment
as this campaign is still unfolding
in 2009 michelle obama uh was in the
capital to unveil a uh bust of the 19th
century suffragist the former slave
sojourner truth and what mrs obama said
at the unveiling is now when girls like
my daughters come to the capitol they
will see a woman who looks like them
and that is
it turns out to be powerful stuff in
american politics that in a sense we
have to see it we have to imagine it and
women in politics will tell you this if
you ask them um that they had models um
that they had figures they had shiros um
who were essential as they figured out
who they could be in their own lifetimes
so in some ways we are at a moment where
we are in the best sense unleashing
a next generation
and i think
very specifically
my expectation is
that
american women in politics
are going to
if you will move the needle on the
question of voting rights in important
ways american women particularly women
of color
know
the burden
of what it means to be kept from the
polls as keenly as anyone in this
country and
we are still not a democracy that
guarantees the right to vote to every
american there are still too many of us
who are kept from the polls by state
level laws
by subterfuge and more we still don't
have a constitutional amendment that
guarantees
to us a ballot
that guarantees to us that we can cast
that ballot that's what we're seeing
played out right here as we are
you know
hurdling toward november and what we're
watching um political leaders fumble
over how on earth we're going to get to
the polls in the midst of a pandemic
i expect
american women to really
take the lead and getting us to the next
level on voting rights and not being
satisfied with the idea that if you live
in georgia
you vote one way if you can vote if you
live in maryland you vote another way
you live in new york yet another way um
i don't know but you my husband is not
american
and he is just flabbergasted
that we are a 21st century democracy
where literally your zip code determines
whether you can vote and how you'll have
to vote what kind of hurdles you'll have
to overcome
so i'm hopeful that um this generation
of american women who live and have come
through the legacy of voter suppression
to be powerful figures will
get us to a place where that ideal right
that has been bandied about for a very
long time which is the ideal of
universal voting rights a guarantee of
the vote
i think
these are the
figures who might just get us there
and just to double click on that because
you hear this argument obviously we're
you know we're going through a pandemic
people are talking about mail-in votes
and
you're hearing arguments from our
president that you know whether it's
secure whether it's reliable in all of
this and i you know this argument we've
heard over the time i'm curious what are
the what are the frictions the barriers
that you think exist today how would you
change them are there good examples of
other countries that have done this well
and that you know the other argument
that if you make it super easy for
everyone to vote it might also make it
super easy to to to double vote or have
fraud or something like that
what's your view of of those types of
arguments
well let's start at the end
there just is no evidence in the united
states
of
widespread consequential voter fraud it
just does not exist
um and we have five or is it six states
in this country where americans vote
all the time by mail um voting by mail
is not an innovation in 2020 it's a
necessity perhaps but there are states
that have long ago gone for example to
voting by mail without any um ill
consequence and so
um the good social science tells us
there are many ways to get people to the
polls
why isn't election day
a holiday
why don't we all have the time and the
leisure to exercise this fundamental
right
and come to the polls to bring our
children to the polls to bring our
elders to the polls to have this be
a national ritual um why is it that the
burden is on us still
for many of us i'm afraid too many of us
to choose between
the risk of
coronavirus
and
the prospect of casting a ballot in my
view the burden should be on the state
to get me the ballot to get you the
ballot to get us our ballots to make
sure we cast them that should be our
right it shouldn't be a privilege that
we
risk ourselves to exercise as it appears
some of us are going to be called upon
to do and so i just i think that um
there's no evidence
that uh
older regimes or new fangled regimes are
more vulnerable to voter fraud than any
other there's just no evidence of
widespread voter fraud at all and the
price we pay
as a democracy is the d legit
legitimization of
our very
political fabric
right because there's no secret now
that you're your cousin um in wisconsin
right can't get to the polls but maybe
you can there's no secret but in oregon
people have been voting for a very long
time by mail
but in my state it's going to take two
or three steps to get that paper ballot
and put it in a mailbox this is now an
open secret in the united states and i
think it undercuts our faith and the
undercuts the in the vote and our the
centrality of the vote um we wonder why
the numbers at the polls
go down in so many communities we lament
right the low
level of voter turnout in this country
but in some sense we have ourselves to
blame for having um
diminished
um the centrality the value access to
the polls
and now we are in a position i think to
have to restore faith in the vote as
fundamental you know i come from
um african-american ancestors who could
not vote for a very long time and i'm a
girl who was taken to the polls long
before she could vote as a lesson right
in my civic responsibility
right to the struggles that black
americans had waged for a very long time
in this country for too long
and i think there are other americans
in their own families
who have stories of what it has meant
to
have access to the polls so one of the
things i encourage people is for elders
to tell those stories out loud so we can
learn from them and for young people to
ask the elders in their midst about the
right to vote
because these are poignant stories
oftentimes that tell us a great deal
about
who we are and who we can be as a
democracy
and and
super valuable and there's a really
interesting it's almost a technical
question but it is something that i
think most
most of us first asked when we first
learned about the suffrage movement
there's a question from facebook
madura
chittnavis marathi asks what is the
original origin of the term suffrage
where and when was it first used
it's a great question
suffrage is an old term um in the
english language and it gets used um
interchangeably with um the ballot and
the vote um throughout the 18th and 19th
century in the early united states but
it does come to
have a specialized connotation i think
now when we look back on the history of
voting rights
one that is closely tied to
this particular movement for voting
rights which
culminates in the 19th amendment
so women's suffrage same i'll say that
my students when i say suffrage
give me that look that boy you hate when
students give you that look but it
happens um that is to say it doesn't
resonate with young people and so i more
and more have been advocating that we
speak even of this
moment in the early 20th century as part
of a longer story of voting rights um i
think that is fair to say that we have
always been engaged in struggles and
questions
and movements for voting rights in this
country going back to the founding and
the movement for women's votes is just
one part of the larger story of american
voting rights
so i'm somebody who could set aside
suffrage altogether if you'd let me but
it's hard to get away from especially in
an anniversary year
yeah absolutely i think after this we
can all do a little bit of homework i'll
look up the etymology because i think
you know obviously teams have
connections to the word suffer but it
has many many meanings i will say
somebody sent me recently the the entry
in in merriam-webster and it's it's it's
an interesting and long one um and the
um connotation of the vote is one of the
more recent connotations of the term one
of the last connotations in webster's um
maybe on its way out i don't know
i'm going to do some research on that
maybe it's like the word passion you
know people say passion of the christ
they're talking about the suffering of
the christ but now
modern term is sup as passion is you
know you you care so much about
something that you suffer i guess um you
know just one last question i always
like to ask this because we have a lot
of young people watching folks who are
trying to chart their own lives you know
what got you interested in becoming a
professor becoming a professor of
history
focused on both civil rights and the
women's rights movement what was kind of
your journey to getting to where you are
now
thanks for that um
i like to tell uh young people i began
uh as a psychology major in uh
college um and i share that to say
um it's a one it's wonderful when in
life you can um follow many kinds of
passions um and chart your own path and
i'm definitely someone who has done that
um
i went to law school
after uh college and spent 10 years as a
public interest lawyer in new york city
and there i was deeply involved in
work related to
economic
and racial justice
but when i had an opportunity to take a
break
i was a history buff but i never had a
chance to study history
and i took a little time off to study
history including the history of my own
family was something that i was
especially interested in and honestly i
got hooked um for me history is like a
treasure hunt we work with um old texts
and documents and um in materials that
nobody has looked at in a very long time
trying to discover the answer to um
questions that still
that still challenge us like this
history of black women in the vote
but i also love being a historian
because i'm part of a community of
scholars of historians of writers of
researchers i don't work alone some days
i do i have to write and it's quiet and
a little lonely but most of the time i'm
part of really exciting discoveries and
conversations and debates with other
historians and i get to spend my time
with young people and students and that
really um is the thing that gets me up
in the morning um the thing that sort of
gets my adrenaline going
and so
i used to be somebody who spent every
day in a courthouse fighting
with other people and i decided maybe i
wanted to be
a lover not a fighter and um come to the
classroom every day and discover new
things about the past and and have
opportunities to share um what i know so
for me it's been um a somewhat
unorthodox journey but it's been a
supremely fascinating one and um and in
this book vanguard i'm able to bring
together right my legal training and my
understanding of the constitution with
my historical training about how
constitutional questions actually happen
on the ground and in people's lives
and then i get to talk with folks like
you all
about that and that's the teacher in me
so
so thanks for that
no well that's super valuable and super
inspiring well martha thank you so much
i think you've given us a lot more
dimensionality to this conversation of
the suffrage movement and and how it
intertwines with the civil rights
movement really valuable
i'm really glad thanks for having me on
sal
thank you so much
well everyone thanks again for joining i
i guess we could call these episodes
another episode of the of the homeroom
live stream i you know hopefully you've
enjoyed this as much as i have as you
can tell this is really kind of a
co-learning journey i'm learning i think
as much as any of y'all are about uh you
know things that
i i thought i knew the first time that i
went through history or actually other
subjects we've even had experts on you
know epidemiology and other sciences on
here as well but there's something when
you get to talk to the experts and look
at what's going on and look at it with
the lens of of the world we live in and
and the context of history you realize
that there's a lot more dimensionality
as i just said to the world and our
stories than we first might realize just
when we read the textbook so thank you
all for joining and i'll see you i think
in a couple of days i i i always lose oh
there there we go on thursday i will see
you
i will see you on uh thursday uh where i
uh i'm going uh to well we're gonna have
a actually wednesday and thursday sorry
it was covered in my screen uh on
wednesday we're gonna talk about some of
the new features at khan academy and
then uh excited about a conversation on
thursday on on really what's going on in
education especially well globally
really so i'll see y'all then
you